we've got some potentially major
geopolitical news breaking today and I
say potentially because it's related to
I guess unconfirmed reports relating to
North and South Korea and unconfirmed by
North Korea so there's a piece out in
the New York Times which says that South
Korea is saying that North Korea is
willing to talk about giving up their
nuclear weapons and this was the message
reportedly from Kim jong-un himself
through some South Korean envoy saying
we are ready we are willing to start
conversations about giving up our nukes
and we'd be willing according to this
report to suspend all nuclear missile
tests during these negotiations and
there has also been an agreement again
this is reportedly as of now from Kim
jong-un himself to hold the summit in
the South Korean with the South Korean
president moon jae-in in the border area
sometime in late April and the statement
about this says quote the North Korean
side clearly stated its willingness to
denuclearize it made it clear that it
would have no reason to keep nuclear
weapons if the military threat to the
north was eliminated and its security
guaranteed now it's possible that North
Korea will deny this as of right now
what we have is a New York Times report
quoting South Korean sources about this
let's assume for a moment that it's
accurate and I have some skepticism and
I'll tell you why in a moment if this is
accurate this would be major this would
really be the first time that the Kim
regime has indicated that they might
give up their nukes if they were given
security guarantees some of those
guarantees would of course have to come
from the United States and they'd
probably relate to the United States as
military presence in South Korea now
we've got to be prepared for the reality
that if this is true Trump's going to
take credit for it right Trump will say
it was either his tough talk or his
bombing of an empty Syrian runway or his
tweets are calling Kim jong-un rocket
or little rocket man or whatever that
caused this to happen and of course the
truth in the real world is that if this
is real it probably relates more to the
overtures made by South Korea including
around the Olympics you'll remember the
athletes from North and South Korea
marching together North Korea sending
Kim Jong Un's sister to the event but
you know what to a certain extent I say
let trump take credit or at least try to
take credit because this has the
potential and again right now it's just
the potential to be a really great thing
and it's not just about it could be good
for the North Korean people of course it
could be good for the people that might
be hit by a North Korean weapon in the
region but the issue of North Korea is
also hamstringing China in many ways and
the relationships of other countries
with China geopolitically because it
puts China the status quo with North
Korea right now puts China and with
really a suboptimal position in terms of
other countries and allies and taking
out the factor of having to constantly
push China to convince North Korea to do
this or convince North Korea not to do
that this could be a very very good
thing in terms of relationships with
China now that being said I want to get
back to some of the caveats here number
one is let's assume for a second the
reports are completely true and Kim
jong-un said everything that's being
reported if you go back to the Clinton
administration Bill Clinton did actually
provide some security guarantees to
North Korea in writing at the time and
North Korea said that they weren't the
right security assurances they weren't
adequate they weren't acceptable or
sufficient security assurances so I'm
not ready to assume that this is Kim
jong-un putting his best foot forward
it could be a pretext to say hey we were
willing but the United States or South
Korea or whoever didn't take it
seriously they didn't act correctly they
didn't give us serious guarantees that
we were looking for and I have to say I
hope I'm wrong right I'm homeboy I hope
I'm wrong about this next part but we
have a long history Kim jong-un
the nukes aren't for negotiation period
in other words when it has brought up
the possibility of talks that would
include stopping the development or
stopping the tests or doing away with
the nuclear weapons that they have it's
been said time and again by Kim jong-un
and his officers that that's just not
something that's a negotiating point and
he's even gone further he has said look
at what happened in Iraq Iraq had sort
of one position geopolitically until
they agreed to stop nuclear weapons
development and get rid of what they had
and then look at what happened to Iraq
so I am very very skeptical but
cautiously optimistic that this might
actually bear fruit yeah so given your
skepticism do you find it odd that this
seems to be a result of the Winter
Olympics and South Korea North Korea
seeming to get along adequately well I'm
I mean you know that politics is weird
and you can have an impasse for decades
and decades and then you never really
know what it is that that's going to
sort of say shake up the situation I'm
sort of agnostic as to what pushes on it
pushes us in a good direction if it does
and I'm sort of waiting to see whether
that's actually what's gonna happen here
yeah I think back to the kennedy and
khrushchev meetings or Reagan and
Gorbachev meeting yet or even like the
Camp David Accords you don't always know
exactly what circumstances will sort of
get you to the table but if everybody's
at the table honestly then you should
take advantage of it and this again I
mentioned the American troops in South
Korea the other sort of cynical
interpretation of Kim Jong Un's actions
if the reports are exactly accurate is
that this could be about trying to get a
guarantee or an agreement or a
concession to get American troops out of
South Korea I don't want to
underestimate the cynicism of Kim
jong-un last thought could this be about
reunification delusions right I don't
know we know that within North Korea and
sort of with external PR North Korea
talks about how any second now there's
going to be reunification between North
and South Korea even though there's no
indication whatsoever that that's going
to happen I don't know whether Kim
jong-un uses that as propaganda or
whether he actually believes it is that
a factor sort of underlying this I don't
but what I can assure you is that there
will be no deal whatsoever until Trump
Pyongyang Golf Club breaks ground and
some Asian guy Trump met met last week
at mar-a-lago is appointed ambassador of
North Korea yeah and it's probably time
to get a US ambassador to South Korea as
well oh we don't have one we don't have
one right now interesting a lot of one
of the many open positions in the world
of Trump the video you just finished
watching was made possible by you
through the membership program you can
sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership